- [Instructor] There are a few definitions
of the term citizenship.
In this video, we're
going to talk about two
of those definitions.
One is the legal definition, the status
of having citizenship.
A person has citizenship
as a member of a state,
which gives them rights,
responsibilities, and privileges.
A citizen of the United States is entitled
to the protections granted
in the Constitution
and Bill of Rights like freedom of speech.
There are two paths to citizenship.
People are either born
citizens because their parents
were citizens or because
they were born on US soil
or they can become naturalized citizens.
We'll talk more in other
videos about the process
to become a citizen but for now just know
that naturalization is the legal process
by which a foreign citizen or national
can become a US citizen.
The other definition of
citizenship I wanna talk about here
is not just the legal
status of having citizenship
but the practice of active citizenship.
You practice good citizenship
by being an informed
and active member of
a political community.
So what does it mean to be a good citizen?
There are a few aspects
of good citizenship.
First, a good citizen is empowered.
That means that they exercise their rights
and believe that they can
make a difference by doing so.
They don't say, "Nah, I'm
not gonna do anything.
"It wouldn't make a difference anyway."
A good citizen is also community-minded.
They feel a sense of responsibility
for their communities
and they wanna help them be
the best that they can be.
They're also inclusive.
And by that I mean that
they wanna do what's best
for everyone in their
community, not just what
would be most beneficial to themselves.
They include multiple
viewpoints and stand up
for the rights of others.
And lastly, a good citizen is informed.
They know how the government
works, they're up to date
on the problems that
the government is facing
and the decisions that it's making.
Good citizens are invaluable to democracy
because democracy works best
when citizens are knowledgeable
and active in political debate.